Thank you, my name is Sebastian Thrun, I'm the founder of Udacity.
I'm super, super delighted to have with me one of the true leaders, pioneers,
and today's contemporary international figures in the age of Artificial Intelligence,
Kai-Fu Lee. Kai-Fu, welcome.
Thank you. I would introduce you the same way.
Thank you. Kai-Fu actually just wrote a book.
It's probably colored red.
It's called AI Superpowers: China,
Silicon Valley, and New World Order.
He's right now on a US book tour. It's selling record levels.
My girlfriend loves the book, so do I.
And you're here with us at Udacity to answer questions and give us some insights.
Yep.
So, welcome.
Thank you.
Well, I should say I've known Kai-Fu for longer than I can imagine.
I used to hear about him back in the day when I was
an exchange student, Masters student at Carnegie Mellon.
He was the guy next door, new faculty member.
And I still remember that the faculty at Carnegie Mellon
believed that they never had a superstar like him among themselves.
And then he moved to Microsoft,
Google, and eventually to China.
started his own venture firm,
Sinovation Ventures in China.
In the book, I’m going to go straight to the chase here.
In the book, you're telling us about AI in China.
Right.
What's different in China from the United States?
Well. China's started very much behind.
There were a lot of decent AI researchers in China.
I was fortunate in 1998 to have founded the Microsoft Research Asia,
which I think ended up training pretty much the whole generation of AI people in China.
But AI wasn't in vogue back then,
it was kind of not very popular.
We didn't even want to use the word AI.
There was a saying that "when it works,
it's product engineering, whatever it doesn't work is AI.
So, we were in that state for quite a while.
But then, US deep learning Geoff Hinton and others really demonstrated that
AI can solve a lot of narrow problems extremely well and China was behind.
But it had this backbone of pretty smart researchers,
and then some of the early China companies like Baidu and Sinovation Ventures,
companies we funded, were doing some work.
But it's really tiny compared to the US.
But what happened was when AlphaGo beat Lee Sedol,
that woke all of China up.
that this ancient game requiring not just intelligence but wisdom,
that how could a US/UK company just beat the best player in Asia,
then there must be something about AlphaGo, about AI.
And then China went on fire in the last two and a half years with entrepreneurs,
VCs, governments all injecting money, talent, resources,
And in the short two and a half years,
China has caught up with the US in implementation,
monetization, and valuation of AI.
And that's what this book is about,
a magical two and a half years
seems like an impossible task.
Mission impossible, but it happened.
So the Chinese government has announced putting tens of billions of dollars into AI.
Yes.
What does it mean and should we do the same in this country(the US)?
Well, first of all, what does it mean?
It actually means infrastructure spending.
I think the Chinese government is not picking winners.
Governments aren't very good at picking winners in technology.
So they're, for example, putting in huge amounts of money to build
a new city the size of Chicago that has autonomous driving built-in,
and within that city,
the center of the town will have two layers.
The pedestrians, pets, bicycles will go on the top, green park,
very beautiful place with no cars.
All the cars, autonomous or not, will drive in B1 in that downtown.
I mean you can imagine the expense,
but that's the kind of effort that I think will make autonomous
driving safe in the most potentially hazardous area,
that is downtown, busy traffic with people, avoiding cars ever hitting people.
So, Zhejiang province is building a new highway with sensors that will talk to cars,
to give cars a lower chance of having accidents.
So, I think that kind of large infrastructure spend is the largest.
Obviously, there's also money being put into AI parks.
The city of Nanjing shows a gigantic area,
I think about two million square feet of space to be its new AI Park,
and because Nanjing had really great schools and they now want to say,
“Hey, AI is now our big big area.”
So, I think infrastructure spend like this are the most powerful.
There's some money being put into AI funds that are investing.
So, yes. A lot of money's being put in.
And I think it's largely in infrastructure, advanced research,
making sure that companies can get funding and their products can take off.
And yes, I think the US should do something like this if that money can be found in the budget.
Yeah. So, in your book,
you talk a bit about values.
You talk about what drives the Chinese entrepreneur.
What makes people successful?
Can you tell us more about the Chinese thinking of entrepreneurship,
about big businesses?
Yeah. Well, I'm a big admirer of Silicon Valley,
but I've also become a big admirer of the Chinese entrepreneurship style,
and I think that's very important to iterating with AI.
So, you know in Silicon Valley,
there's Steve Jobs with the iPhone as the typical.
What you're doing with Kitty Hawk is another great example.
And Udacity.
And Udacity. Yes. Udacity is a little bit-
A much bigger company.
Udacity is a bit more like Chinese-style.
How so?
Well, I think, you know, Kitty Hawk,
iPhone is like a brilliant breakthrough technology that's going to
change the world. The light bulb goes off and brilliant scientists leading forward.
I think Udacity is wonderful but it's
more, you know, operational excellence, getting more people, getting more content.
So, that's actually something the Chinese really excel at.
And in the book I talk about, you know, in the US there's a book called The Lean Startup,
but actually China does the Lean Startup better than Silicon Valley,
and also takes the Lean Startup from zero to one,
and then one to a million.
So, because the Chinese entrepreneurial environment is very,
very tough, people compete fiercely.
In the book I talk about, it's like Colosseum,
where gladiators are thrown in and only one will survive.
And also, there's not much frowning on copycats.
I'm not talking about IP theft,
I'm just talking about taking the look and feel from
another product within legal bounds or a feature.
So, in that kind of environment,
the only way companies can win is by building a product that is impregnable, and uncopyable.
So, the examples I give in the book are the Chinese Yelp or Groupon called Meituan,
It would go through so much trouble and depth to
create an infrastructure that will change the way Chinese people eat.
And once you build that infrastructure,
competitors can't copy it or it's too expensive to copy.
And that infrastructure, essentially allows food to be delivered to your home within 30 minutes.
You'd have a choice of maybe 500 restaurants,
Before you leave work, you choose what you want to eat.
When you're home in 30 minutes, the food is there waiting for you,
And the cost of delivery is about $0.70.
And the way in which they achieved that operational excellence
is by grinding away a few cents a month,
figuring out new ways, how to find people who will work for less money,
how to find cheaper ways of transportation,
such as cheaper electrical mopeds,
and then how to deal with change of batteries.
and also the people, since they're not making a lot of money, there will be turnover.
So, having an HR process that has
600,000 people with massive turnover every year.
All of this to Silicon Valley feels like a lot of operational burden,
but by doing it well and getting the delivery down to $0.70,
you've essentially erected a very high wall around
your business so that your competitor,if they want to do the same,
they have to spend a few billion dollars.
So, it's like the Amazon,
where we have Jeff Bezos “we have so thin margins I'm proud of it”
It is like that.
Eric Schmidt recently very famously said in a confidential meeting that made it to
the press, that he sees there being two versions of the Internet.
There'd be an Internet run by
the world and maybe a Chinese Internet run by China.
What do you think about that?
Well, if you look at my phone and my apps,
they are completely different from yours.
So, from that perspective,
absolutely. The Chinese people are using all Chinese apps and they've gotten very good.
You know, WeChat is better than WhatsApp.
I saw that you are still using WhatsApp.
I'm not quite yet using WhatsApp.
What was that you use to send?
Most for text messaging, yeah.
With text messaging?
Oh, my God, you don't know.
Oh, my God.
Beats me.
The CEO of Kitty Hawk using text messaging.
I mean, WeChat. Well, the Chinese apps are really, really good.
Actually, the ones that were inspired by the US,
often they get better than the US.
Not always, but often.
And there are many now that are not inspired by the US, they're Chinese innovation.
like there are two social networks with video.
They don't exist here yet,
and there's a gamification of e-commerce that in three years became $25 billion.
So, all these concepts are now innovative in China,
the apps are different,
the Chinese users don't use much American apps and vice-versa.
So, I think in that sense, I agree.
Speaking about this, I mean,
there's a whole bunch of companies,
Udacity being no exception,
who try do business in China,
then starts opening offices in China,
having joint ventures or similar vehicles.
What's your advice for an American company who wants to go into the Chinese business?
Well, I think Udacity is actually a very exceptional case.
I think because what you carry is education and that's dear and common to all the people.
So, there are few such things that can potentially cross the US and China.
Pure core technology companies,
educational content, entertainment are
probably three that I think can cross the boundaries.
All the other things will be very, very tough.
Take Google, Facebook, Amazon, Uber, or Airbnb.
They all have a very hard time in China.
And why is that?
Well, the Chinese have parallel universe that has been established,
people have established patterns of how they use WeChat, Alibaba, Taobao,
and so on and the brands are established,
the apps are very easy to use,
they cater to the Chinese way,
and they're intertwined in the way that, you know, if you use the Chinese ride-sharing system,
then you're naturally going to use WeChat
which is then naturally going to cause you to use WeChat Pay.
So, these things are like a puzzle put together.
If you now grab Amazon and say we're going to put that puzzle and make
it fit in
this already completed Chinese puzzle, it just doesn't fit.
So, my advice to most American companies that want to go to China is don't,
unless you are in education,
technology license, entertainment. Those areas I think are okay.
I mean over time I do hope the two universes will have a chance to cross,
but right now it's just very hard.
Interesting. I’m gonna come back to your book.
This is gonna be the book to read for everybody for a long time to come
in my opinion and I should say Kai-Fu Lee is truly apparently effective.
When I joined Carnegie Mellon,
my first program was to work on something called Bill, which was
a world-class machine-learning Othello player designed by a professor
called Kai-Fu Lee who sits next to me and he is a world-class programmer,
I can attest to this.
But I want to ask you about the AI end game.
So, the AI is now in everybody's mind,
we have people like Elon Musk saying AI will eat us for breakfast,
Stephen Hawking says it's the biggest threat in humanity.
Bill Gates has been skeptical about it. What is the end game?
Well, I think we cannot project an end game when we don't know the next 20 moves,
we're talking about, you know, Othello end goal right?
Right now, we have a narrow AI,which is within a single domain,
you can train brilliant systems that can play Go,
that can make decisions for loan officers,
advertising agents, accountants, paralegal, reporters.
I think we're at the stage where we have this blossoming of narrow AI,
and then the chasm between narrow AI to general AI,
the so-called end game of human intelligence is like
a black dark hole that I can't see
any moves that will clearly get us from here to there.
So, my opinion is that I think of narrow AI not as a first step,
but as maybe the most important step. And it is like electricity,
where apps can be built and it will create so much value and
wealth and also displace a lot of jobs and present challenges.
So, this book is actually just saying,
"this first step is really important,
let's play it right,
and then if there's another step,
we've got to survive the first step and make humanity better."
So, I don't talk about the end game.
Do you believe in general artificial intelligence?
I do not.
Why not?
I choose to believe that we have a soul and that it cannot be replicated.
I know this may not be the most popular view within the AI geeky community.
Do you believe that without a soul we can
accomplish a machine that can do many different tasks?
I do, I believe we can.
So, I think I see narrow AI becoming smarter.
You know, it will have more and more capabilities. Autonomous driving, I mean Kitty Hawk,
those are great examples, that single task is already multi-complex tasks,
but I don't think Kitty Hawk has a soul,
I don't think it can understand compassion and empathy,
and I don't think people want to have robots to take care of them,
be their nanny, and nurse,
and doctor, and teacher.
Let me push this a little bit.
So, if I gave you a machine and say this is
a piece of AI and it can take care of elderly people.
How would you tell whether the machine has a soul or not?
Well, I would say elderly people don't want it.
So, if they don't want the product then it won't succeed.
I've actually had an entrepreneur who built a pretty good robot for
elderly care and it turns out that elderly people
only use one function and that's called Customer Service.
So, they push customer service
to talk to a person?
A video comes up and then the elderly person says,
"Why hasn't my daughter called today?
Let me tell you about my grandson."
And I think there is an innate desire for people to interact with other people.
So, even if the robot became quite good,
it won't be the choice by the people.
Now there has been work on AI, just to push a little harder here.
Okay.
That you see from University of Washington and other places that
people are able to synthesize
famous individuals like President Barack Obama in a way that looks believable.
In fact, Udacity and our work with Georgia Tech.
A Georgia Tech professor built an online agent,
an online TA that throughout
the entire class acted like a TA. And when the class was over,
first this clone was actually a piece of A.I. not
a human being and every student was completely surprised.
Do you think we cannot cross the chasm where we find AI agents believable?
I think we can make them believable for certain tasks
and there are many tasks for which we really don't need the human interaction.
The teaching assistant may just as well be Duolingo,right?
It doesn't have to be anthropomorphized.
I think there are many things that require that human connection and that I don't see
any progress that gives me
confidence we can cross that bridge. And that bridge is meant to be,
you know, we really build something that's a completely indistinguishable from human.
I think it potentially brings disasters to us.
Supposing it's doable, in the sense
that what is the purpose and the meaning of our lives?
And I think that will then cause a likely dystopia.
So, I'm not saying it's impossible to build a machine with a soul,
but I think we have to right now not believe
it because I think having our soul and humanity
is important and therefore people who choose
to go after it they of course have the freedom to.
But I think for the most of us,
I think we need to hang onto our humanity,
believe that we are unique and have our soul.
And at the end of the day, I think if we are right,
then we never fall into a downward vicious cycle of feeling of worthless.
And even in the case we're wrong,
I think believing we have a soul will make our lives more worth living,
even if 100 years later Sebastian's student prooves that we're wrong,
this 100 years will be better lived even if we're wrong.
So there's a window left. This is really insightful, let me change gears a little bit.
So, if you are a large-scale company,
you're like an AT&T and Verizon, a healthcare company like,
Kartner Health, and you heard about the AI in the news,
you read Kai-Fu's book,
and you want to engage.
What do you advise companies to do?
Well, they have to recognize AI is coming and for
the sake of their shareholders and their company's survival,
they need to look at how to apply AI and make more money,
as well as to displace humans in many of the jobs that Narrow AI can do.
And also I think in doing so,
they need to take on responsibility of the employees they would
displace over the next five years that they are not just objects.
Because if every company only optimizes shareholder value,
there will be tens of millions of people on
the streets because AI has taken their job and they can't
find another job. Because whatever they can do, AI can do better,
because AI will be displacing the most routine,
the least skilled jobs,
and it’ll be the hardest for people to find a new job.
So, I like to think that
a large company that can reap the rewards of using AI to displace its workers,
ought to also have the responsibility to find training to help their employees find
jobs that are not immediately displaced or hopefully never displaced by AI.
We just would say AT&T has been doing this very massively
but let's dive into this.
Do you think AI will be as big as like the Fourth Industrial Revolution?
Certainly, absolutely.
And what fraction of the labor force in
developed nations like China and
the United States do you think this is going to be replaced?
I think if we project further,
15 to 25 years,
Yes.
Probably about 50%.
50% is what McKinsey says.
What type of jobs do you think are most under fire right now?
At this moment, it's not so bad.
At this moment actually AI is creating a lot of jobs，right?
People taking Udacity courses, getting into AI.
and AI is creating a lot of jobs for people
who have the potential skill set and interest,
and the actual displacement are just being tweaked right now.
But one of the reasons I wrote the book is that we're an investor in many companies,
and we can basically count which ones are doing job displacements.
We see, for example,
we have invested in companies that are doing robotics for dishwashing,
fruit picking, loan officers,
customer service, traders,
waiters and waitresses,
fast food cooks, cashiers.
So, I can think of eight jobs already with the technologies,
that I see making rapid progress.
You could add taxi drivers I assume，and truck drivers.
That's right, we are investing in autonomous vehicle, yes.
Those will be quite a bit later.
But the eight professions I mentioned, I think, between 3 to 10 years,
they'll be largely gone.
What I find fascinating about those professions that you mentioned is two things,
One, they're low skilled labor.
Yes.
And second, they often have a physical extension, where you
can't pick fruits by just having a computer thinking about picking fruits,
but they have to be a physical robot and that robot has to be food safe.
Do you envision a new age of robotics?
An age of robotics as in robots getting smarter and able to manipulate people?
If you look at the business of robotics from my perspective, except for self-driving cars,
I can't point at a single robotic technology that has really succeeded at scale.
There's bits and pieces,
there's Kiva and Amazon, advancements like in shelf delivery,
and my analysis has always been like, in addition to being smart,
you also have to pay for the hardware and maintain the hardware.
Yeah.
But you're saying, "No,
not so fast, Sebastian."
There's all kinds of drops there.
It's not just the eyes, but also the physical actuation
that's going to make enough progress. Is that what you're saying?
Yes. I think I'm predicting that,
but I also am more cautious in projecting that slowly and,
we have to see there's equivalent progress in the mechanical aspects.
But I believe we're seeing progress and also computer
vision and deep learning and those technologies are getting integrated,
and we're seeing functional prototypes,
Actually probably, the first one will be the Kiva 2.0,right?
The version that's completely human free in the warehouse putting things in boxes.
That I think we certainly see.
If you're a young entrepreneur, be it in the United States,
in China, or anywhere in the world,
what should you work on if you want to do something significant in AI?
Well.
What are your best ideas? No one's listening.
Well, if you're into making money,
the lowest hanging fruit has to be in
the financial areas because those are fabricated human
games of simulation that were never meant for people to do.
So, all the banks,
insurance companies, payments, investments,
Because you end up with a cash printing machine
once your algorithm works.
It doesn't have all the robotics,
the warehouse, and manufacturing delivery, all those things.
So, I think if you're into making money,
there's still space in financial indusrty.
Yeah.
If you're into making a huge difference,
then I think getting into robotics autonomous vehicle,
the breakthroughs there will probably come back to help many things become possible.
Okay.
Autonomous vehicle I think is a particularly challenging one.
I'm not as optimistic as Waymo in saying,
okay we're going to deploy this year and next year,
this and that will happen.
But I think with so many smart people and money going into it,
with all the automotive companies and
electrical vehicle companies having given up to autonomous vehicles,
I think they will eventually make progress and change the way we transport ourselves.
And when that happens, a lot of those technologies will then come back to robotics and
maybe solve the robotic problems that you think maybe are hard to solve at the moment.
Anyway if anyone is listening, we have an AI for Finance Nanodegree that just launched.
But more importantly, blockchain.
So I've heard opinions about blockchain,from like
"this is just a nice piece of the puzzle", or perhaps,
"this is great for drug money", all the way to “it’s going to change everything”, where do you stand?
I think we've got to solve the POW problem.
That is the large amount of
computation needed to maintain the inalterability of contracts.
So, when someone solves that problem, either with
some form of computation that doesn't kill us with energy,
or with a non-computing intensive approach,
then I think it can take off,
I think there will be many applications.
Would you invest in Blockchain?
Yes.
You have invested in blockchain?
Only in a great company called BitMe, it is somewhat of a blockchain company.
It's the largest Bitcoin mining hardware company.
When we look at this layers of things you can invest in,such as their ICOs,
and crypto, we are very worried about fraud there.
We look at Blockchain,
we don't see the killer app or worry about POW,
but from an investment standpoint,
the one place you can't lose is whatever the apps are,
you gotta keep the mining going.
You got to have the CPU.
You’re gonna do the shovel,
like in El Dorado, California, everyone is mining for gold, okay,
and occasionally people succeed. But you have
a fixed business because you give everyone the same shovel.
That's right. This is our single, only investment in blockchain.
Nice.
And I think we've been pretty smart in doing that.
If you were a bank and you'd just been here with Dodd Frank,
with Basel III and all these regulation that came up with the 2008 crisis,
and you're racking up literally hundreds of millions of
dollars every year in regulatory and compliance costs,
should you worry about blockchain?
If I were a bank, I'd just shut myself
down because I'm not doing any good for the society.
I’m just kidding. I think it should all be electronic.
I'm partly kidding but partly serious because we're in China.
The credit card companies are already gone.
You know the mobile payment has already taken over and that 2%
of tax that, you know, that's been placed on the western world is gone.
China just freed itself from
a 2% tax from not having to use credit cards by using
purely, this is not blockchain nor is it crypto,
it's just real solid normal Renminbi currency that is being exchanged on WeChat.
I mean, in China you see people paying each other always by phone.
Nobody carries cash. People don't have credit cards,
even beggars on the street are there holding up a sign that says,
"I'm hungry, scan me."
you know, and I think in that we see the future of money,
and whether there's blockchain or crypto, maybe...
So, what can, say, Jamie Dimon from JP Morgan Chase or Urs Rohner from Credit Suisse.
What can we actually learn from China?
Well, I think the future of finance will go completely virtual.
I think all the people in banks are doing jobs like routine, you know, lab rats in a wheel.
They should all be done by AI.
So, I realize there are a lot of regulations that don't allow banks to just go away.
But, I think banks will probably be too slow to reinvent themselves,
with blockchain or without.
And we will end up with really just virtual currency,
virtual banks, and pay less and less.
I mean, if credit cards are taking a 2% tax,
banks surely are taking another 2% tax on this society,
Insurance companies surely are taking another 2%.
I just look forward to the day that this narrow A.I. will displace
those things and give that 6% back to us that we're entitled to.
Some insurance companies live by leveraging risk.
And if AI were to be really smart, it would say things like,
okay your number one factor of risk is your pre-existing conditions,
and number two factor of risk is your lifestyle as
measured by your credit score or whatever you use for lifestyle measurement.
It doesn't even take AI to get there.
Don't you worry that we’ll get into a world where we just don't have
insurance anymore and there will just be winners and losers?
No, I think insurance should be
personalized based on the risks you have and the need you have.
So I think everyone should be able to design his or her own insurance needs of saying,
well I want, you know, you can in natural language
describe that if I die I want my family to have this much money.
So how much do I need to pay you?
And click, and then a personalized policy will come and you pay for that.
And if you have a pre-existing condition, you're gonna pay twice as much?
If you have a pre-existing condition, I mean...
You went through pre-existing conditions some time in your life.
I do. I do. (What do you think?) If the governments want to enforce that, insurance companies must do something,I mean,
whether it's virtual or physical, they can enforce that.
I mean yes, my medical insurance did not abandon me
once I had cancer. And I can't
get any other insurance company so I better hang onto this one,
But the same can apply to a virtual insurance, no?
Okay. I'm going to change course a little
bit and talk about the young people because many of
our Udacity fellows are people in the world aspiring to
be even 10% of who you are, Kai-Fu Lee,
You're a role model to many of us, myself included.
But if you face your younger self,
say at Tsinghua University,
or at Carnegie Mellon University,
what advice would you give to your younger self?
Well especially considering that the age of AI is coming,
I think it is all the more important that
the young people follow their hearts and do things they're passionate about,
because what the world tells you is increasingly getting outdated.
Because I think a lot of parents and a lot of jobs in the society would
have us think that some jobs are very desirable because they're stable and
safe, or some jobs are desirable because they're high paying.
But AI would disrupt a lot of that,
Take radiologists for example,
if you're going to a medical school, don't be a radiologist.
Don't be a dermatologist either.
Yeah exactly, don't be a dermatologist.
Yeah, yeah. You did some work on that, right?
You and Andrew are both doing great work on that.
But do be a researcher.
So one is do what you're good at and what you love,
and second is, be aware of what AI is going to replace and don't go into those areas.
Go into the areas where AI will enhance.
Think about AI as either a job destroyer or a job enhancer.
Pick the jobs where AI can be a job enhancer.
Be a medical researcher,
that is a great, great area,
But some jobs will go away.
Also, I think it's important to improve
the human interaction skills because that's one thing AI cannot do,
It is that true human touch,
the compassion, the empathy,
the altruism, the connection and the trust with people,
and those soft skills sometimes are being
forgotten by young people who spend all their time on the phone.
So do spend time making friends,
going to teamwork activities.
Even before the age of AI, we know that incorporations,
people with strong EQ actually,
is more important than the IQ.
Of course you want both, but everything else being equal,
you have a basic level of both,
people with high EQ are generally the ones who really progress well in their careers.
Interesting. I’m gonna to ask you one last question.
and I believe nobody answers it but,
I’m gonna ask you anyhow because you are one of the leaders.
Do you think that there will ever be an age where we can upload ourselves into a computer?
I'm going to say no.
Never.
I would not like that to happen.
Historians in the world take a moment, notice here:
Kai-Fu Lee, world expert says,
we'll never be able to put ourselves in a box.
Well, I am not saying we can never do it,
I'm saying I would very much like the answer to be no.
The reason is I think our life has meaning because of our mortality,
and this pursuit for immortality would disrupt the reasons of
how we live our lives and I think there's
a lot of wisdom (we've) accumulated over thousands of years.
So, if we offer immortality to people, I worry
that our humanity will change in a way that may be very negative.
I'm not projecting it to be possible or not possible,
but I would very much like for it not to be.
Would you invest in Chinese version of Calico that tries to double human lifespan?
To increase longevity or to create immortality?
To make you live twice as long.
Increase longevity, okay.
Yes, I absolutely would.
Up to what point? I mean beyond this point,
Well, our bodies.
to 200? 250? 300?
Well, our bodies are only durable for 120 years, right?
How you know?
Well, maybe your children's,
children's bodies can live longer.
I think our bodies have already been ruined by toxins and things like that.
I was told 120,
but I think having longevity doubling I would love to invest in that.
Okay, now since I didn't, I’m now on my final question:
Among all the great things being discussed today, from doubling human lifespan, to cold fusion,
to flying cars, to curing all diseases,
what do you think is going to actually happen in the next 30 or 40 years?
Well, I think a lot will happen.
I think flying cars will clearly happen,
autonomous vehicles will clearly happen,
narrow AI taking half the jobs that will clearly happen.
That's big.
Yeah a lot of the current traditional institutions
will go out of business. That's for sure.
I think there will be progress in things like immunology,
lengthening of our lives' longevity.
I think CRISPR hopefully will find a good direction that can help us be better.
And also I think AI will
definitely cause a couple of
small disasters and hopefully we'll be in a position to control them.
Kai-Fu Lee, we're out of time so I can't ask 'what the disasters are' question.
But it's so incredible to have you here.
Thank you.
You are one of my role models.
I've known you for more than 20 years, and it's so
great to have you on stage today here at Udacity.
Thank you.
And buy this book.
Thanks!